[Musique]
notre invité politique ce matin ces
sachets ollier bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous députés la république
en marge de la vienne on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par florent buisson
bon jean florent bonjour journalistes à
la république du centre on commence avec
le secteur de l'aéronautique en grande
difficulté un sachet ollier 5000 emplois
qui vont être supprimés chez airbus
d'ici l'été 2021 7500 emplois menacés
chez air france et ce malgré les 15
milliards mis sur la table par le
gouvernement pour aider le secteur
aérien est ce que c'est un camouflet
pour l'état d'abord il faut rappeler
quelle est l'orientation que nous
prenons sur ces secteurs et sur la
relance économique
ce qu'on assume c'est de faire de la
dépense publique pour soutenir tous les
secteurs en difficulté vous avez évoqué
le secteur de l'aéronautique g revenir
précisément mais le secteur du btp de la
culture de l'automobile et sur ces
sujets là on le dit on et 15 jan east
ont fait la dette publique on relance et
on investit et on assume
nous l'état dans la droite ligne de ce
qu'on a construit également avec les
prêts garantis avec les fonds de
solidarité avec l'activité réduite
on en reparle également mais on assume
donc c'est l'orientation pour
l'aéronautique
ces 15 milliards d'euros et ses 15
milliards d'euros qui se manifeste par
de la commande publique où l'état va
investir 15 milliards d'euros qui se
manifestent pour de l'investissement des
renouvellements de flottes la protection
et la préservation des emplois et à la
fin la protection des salariés et sur le
chiffre que vous venez d'annoncer c'est
le chiffre initial en ambitionner si on
peut le dire ainsi par airbus
mais ce n'est pas nécessairement le
chiffre définitif puisque d'abord l'état
a demandé à ce que airbus protège les
salariés et donc détruit moins d'emplois
que l'on avait prévu va pas se raconter
des histoires la filière ne va pas bien
les flottes ont été arrêtés les
commandes ont été interrompues et donc
on ne pourra pas sauver toute la filière
pour convoler terreur à moins de 5000
emplois détruits chez airbus c'est ce
qu'a demandé le gouvernement
c'est ce que nous devons nous attacher à
faire et c'est ce que nous devons nous
attacher à faire à la fois par les
commandes que je vous ai écrites mais
aussi par les mécanismes de protection
de l'emploi
qu'est ce que c'est c'est à dire que
l'activité réduite qu'on a vu si
performante et qui pour la france l'une
des bières du monde
l'activité réduite elle doit se
prolonger en longues
et jusqu'à deux ans après la sortie du
des conflits du coup fondement
ce qui veut dire que le but encore une
fois il est de ne pas détruire des
emplois
cette stratégie justement quand on voit
les chiffres les chiffres de
descriptions d'emploi alors peut-être
notamment chez air france est-ce qu'il
faut se montrer plus ferme avec air
france qui parle de 7500 de destruction
de l'emploi mais sur cette question il
enfin il faut être les plus exigeants
possible parce que c'est de l'argent
public qui est consacré à la relance
économique
par contre si on promet à tout le monde
que on va pouvoir sauver tous les
emplois
on ment et on ne peut pas mentir par
contre ce qu'on peut promettre ce qu'on
doit promettre est sûr qu'on s'engage
c'est quelque chose qui est une des
finalement l'un des marqueurs
idéologiques de la république en marche
on a été élu en 2017 pour lutter contre
le chômage de masse jusque là on y était
parvenu jusqu'à cette crise cette crise
qui était d'abord sanitaires et qui est
maintenant économique et social et on y
était parvenu parce qu'on est persuadé
que sur des mécanismes comme le dialogue
social avec des accords comme savait le
cas sur les mécanismes comme l'activité
réduite
eh bien on peut permettre de protéger
l'emploi industriel on avait recréer de
l'emploi industriel à la sortie du
confinement
on arrive tout de suite à recréer des
emplois certes bien moins que ce qu'on a
détruit jusqu'à présent va pas les
emplois mais par exemple sur air france
sur la france c'est à ce chiffre de 7
milliards qui sont en fait des prêts
garantis par les braises qui est ce
qu'il aurait fallu récup italy's est
clairement air france de ces 7 milliards
mais pas que parce que si vous les deux
panels est assez large
il ya effectivement du prêt garanti il
ya effectivement des fonds
d'investissement est effectivement des
achats publics et puis elle voyez que le
panel il est très large
le panel il est très large et on ne
néglige aucun outil par contre on
demande lorsque ces outils sont utilisés
qu'ils fassent le biais de contrôle et
le but du parlement soit dans le cadre
des différents projets de loi de
finances qui sont votées soit dans le
cadre du projet de loi rectificatif
pardon parce que effectivement on a voté
1 2 on est en train d'examiner le
troisième soit dans le cadre du futur
projet de loi de finances pour 2010 21
qui sera un morceau impressionnant parce
que il va contenir des mesures qui
seront au soutien au plan de relance qui
n'ont pas d'autres urgences mais est-ce
que c'est pas tout le secteur de l'air
de l'aéronautique pardonnez moi qui est
à réinventer finalement
c'est précisément ce que nous avons dit
lorsque nous avons pris les plans
sectoriels 18 milliards pour le tourisme
plus d'un milliard et demi pour la
culture 15 milliards pour l'automobile
15 milliards pour l'aéronautique
si on aligne ces chiffres là ça ne parle
pas français ça veut rien dire par
contre quand on rentre dans le détail
quand je vous disais que ça c'est de
l'aide financière est ce que derrière
une réflexion globale sur qui est en
danger on va prendre l'exemple de
l'aéronautique tout de suite donc on se
dit que effectivement il ya un
investissement pour la commande publique
escolo fixe aussi comme cap c'est qu'à
horizon 2035
on est le premier avion zéro carbone est
donc finalement l'idéal est de se dire
instruit de l'actrice de berne suisse
tiendra jusqu'à 2035 instruit la crise
de 2008 où il y avait eu des primes à la
casse qui avaient été faites mais sans
objectifs de long terme de transformer
l'économie sur l'aéronautique ou sur
l'automobile on veut que la relance
économique
elles permettent aussi de faire la
transition écologique et ça pour le coup
c'est un défi et ce que nous y
parviendrons
c'est un pari qu'on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui c'est sûr et certain on va y
arriver
par contre c'est l'ambition que nous
donnons et ça il faudra ensuite pouvoir
le suivre c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
parlementaires au delà sur ces questions
d'emploi on parle d'un million de
chômeurs supplémentaires voire plus
malheureusement est ce que les
dispositifs prévus par le gouvernement
sont suffisants ou est ce que vous dites
il faudra aller encore plus loin
d'abord ce qu'il faut admettre sur cette
question encore une fois je vous disais
que sur ces questions d'emploi c'est
quelque chose qui nous était absolument
cher c'est ce que nous avons le plus
porté dans la campagne de 2017 et c'est
ce qui me préoccupe le plus avec ce
chiffre que je vous donnais à l'instant
de dire que s'il ya eu aujourd'hui des
milliers les centaines d'amis des
destructions d'emplois notamment par
l'arrêt de l'intérim avec un décrochage
incroyable d'intérim on a eu dès le mois
de mai dès la reprise
cent cinquante mille nouvelles créations
donc ce qui est finalement assez fin
dans ce que nous avons créé nous avons
cherché d'abord à protéger les
entreprises qui emploient c'est le fond
de ce les fonds de solidarité c'est les
prêts garantis et c'est tout la
protection de l'appareil productif
ensuite ce qu'on a cherché à protéger
sont les compétences
ce qu'on ne veut pas c'est de détruire
de l'emploi industriel de détruire de
l'emploi qualifié parce que les
compétences que l'on détruit maintenant
les emplois finalement que qu'ils sont
qui font l'objet d'un licenciement ou
d'arrêt d'activité ont les recrues que
très difficilement et donc si on ne
protège pas ses salariés eh bien on se
prive de compétences pour la reprise que
nous espérons le plus tôt possible
c'est pour ça que l'activité réduite ou
le chômage partiel appelez le comme vous
voulez ça m'est égal mais c'est pour ça
que ce dispositif
il a été le plus généreux du monde dans
le confinement il est demeuré à la
sortie du confinement comme l'un des
plus protecteur et des négociations ont
été entreprises avec tous les syndicats
dans l'équipe avec tous les syndicats
qui sont assez demandeurs est assez
porteur de ces deux mesures parce que
tant au medef qu'à la cfdt ou à la cgt
vous avez des échos qui sont favorables
la signature c'est pour ça que ça soit
prise en charge par l'état et par les
entreprises il faut garder la même
répartition de prise en charge entre
l'état et les entreprises
alors au sur cette question là il ya
deux types de discussions il ya une
discussion sur comment s'est aménagé
dans les entreprises et notamment des
accords savez que c'est aussi notre
culture que de dire on fait confiance
aux salariés au plus proche du terrain
et on voit par ailleurs que c'est
possible puisque vous avez des le sucre
et on en parlait avec le secrétaire
général de force ouvrière qui dit nous
c'est possible on est capable de le
faire donc désaccord dans les
entreprises au plus près pour sauver
l'emploi
là où ils existent dans les territoires
et puis ensuite une activité réduite
avec derrière un montant de prise en
charge qui aujourd'hui 2 85% qui est au
1er octobre sera de 60 %
mais naturellement donc il pourra sans
voix qui bêlent ce sera progressif
ce sera progressif et on parle d'un
objectif 1er octobre donc vous voyez que
on n'est pas là pour sabrer reste au
plus fort de la crise et d'alcas et bien
dans ce cas là nous poserons la question
collectivement gouvernement parlement de
savoir s'il ne faut pas réhausser les
mesures s'il faut pas reprendre en
charge plus de salaire s'il faut pas
voir avoir une action un peu baissé est
remonté à un moment donné sur l'emploi
nous avons une religion absolue c'est la
protection des séries je voulais un seul
exemple pour que l'on puisse et du site
qu'un exemple qui a ses actes on a fait
la réforme de l'assurance chômage par
décret avec trois types de mesures
la dégressivité puisque ça allait mieux
aller mieux donc la période d'intimité
baisser les taxations sur les contrats
courts et puis ensuite la question de
l'assurance chômage pour les
indépendants partout loin dès lors que
la conjoncture économique s'est retourné
elle a changé et vire on s'est dit que
les deux premiers types de mesures
soient l'indemnisation sur une période
plus courte soit la taxation des
contrats courts notamment en intérim ou
sur des secteurs comme la restauration
l'hôtellerie
ça n'était plus tenable donc nous
l'avons suspendue avant de voir ce que
nous en ferons définitivement voyez que
nous avons un objectif qu'un objectif
principal majeur ultime qui est celui de
la création d'emplois et que les mesures
pour y parvenir elles peuvent varier
dans le temps
dès lors que nous atteignons notre
objectif qui est principal cette crise
sanitaire elle a eu des conséquences
pour les associations qui sont souvent
vital pour les personnes en grande
précarité comment on fait pour aider ces
associations d'abord moi j'avais tenu
lorsque les choses sont on commençait à
rentrer dans l'ordre
il commençait à rentrer dans l'ordre
partir du 11 mai où on a des consignes
et à les voir en premier rang les
associations d aide aux démunis
donc vous inciter certaines c'est les
restos du coeur c'est le secours
populaire le secours catholique la croix
rouge bref mon corps emmaüs et toutes
ces associations qui ont été en première
ligne parce que qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé qu'est ce qu'ils disent ces
personnes ils disent on a vu les
personnes retirées des colis
alimentaires dont on n'avait jamais
qu'on n'avait jamais connu auprès au
préalable alors dès le mois d'avril il y
avait 39 millions d'euros qui ont été
déployés ensuite dans les territoires
sur les associations tête de pont pour
donner cela il y avait cette annonce
aussi qui a été faite du la prime
exceptionnelle aux plus démunis cas pas
forcément été comprise par tous mais qui
était absolument nécessaire
150 euros pour une personne qui
touchaient le rsa 100 euros pour un
ménage qui touchent des apl le taux
majoré de 100 euros à chaque fois qu'il
y avait un enfant et puis on s'aperçoit
c'est pas suffisant
donc est ce qu'on fait et c'est ce que
vient d'annoncer christelle du vestiaire
ces 55 millions d'euros en plus sur ces
questions là encore une fois personne ne
sera laissé au bord du chemin
on a bien compris qu'il y avait un
problème de précarité alimentaire
on connaît le problème de précarité
global qu'entraîne ce type de crise et
on sait que finalement il n'y a pas de
meilleur acteur que l'état ce qui
m'inspire deux types de réactions
la première les gens viennent chercher
ces êtres pardonnez moi je reviens sur
les
ils en viennent le chercher où il est
clairement parce qu'on sait qu'il ya une
difficulté chez certaines personnes en
difficulté justement à taper à la porte
de l'état pour obtenir des aides elles y
viennent les chercher pour une simple et
bonne raison c'est que l'aide que nous
avons alloué qui est l'aide
exceptionnelle que je vous décris elle
était automatique et pour ce qui
concerne ensuite écoles élémentaires
c'est les associations qui nous font
état d'une sur fréquentation
donc oui ils viennent et quand je vous
dis que ça m'inspire de deux choses
c'est d'abord que nous sommes assez
lucide par rapport à cette situation que
nous voulons résoudre
par contre il faudra tirer toutes les
conséquences aussi de ce qui est cette
politique là et dans la loi
décentralisation déconcentration bref
dans la réorganisation des pouvoirs je
ne suis pas sûr que les collectivités
dans leurs toutes leurs différences
soient les plus à même d'être celles qui
détiennent les compétences sociales
parce qu'il faut une uniformité sur ce
sujet et nous en parlions il ya aussi
que ce sont elles qui sont les plus
proches d'eux des citoyens donc qu'elles
sont proches de le faire pour pour
décliner les politiques publiques mais
comment expliquer aujourd'hui une
différence de versement des prestations
sur le rsa sur les allocations pour les
personnes handicapées sur les appels sur
la protection de l'enfance parce que où
vous êtes d'un département à l'autre et
que parfois la seule chose qui vous
sépare cette mathilde m ça leur
retourner dans le giron de l'état c'est
une question que nous devons nous poser
c'est une question que j'ai posée hier
au défenseur des droits et c'est une
question à laquelle le défenseur des
droits at émis l'idée appuyé l'idée que
je proposais qui est de dire que cette
compétence pourrait revenir dans le
giron de l'état
et est-ce qu'on gagnerait en efficacité
est ce que c'est ça aussi parfois le
problème notamment des appels
il faudra gagner en efficacité et fera
surtout gagné en égalité en équité
notation dont on traite les gens et
parce que ça pour le coup dans la crise
que nous allons vivre et que nous
combattrons de toute notre force puisque
je crois que c'est notre objectif
principal
là encore il faudra pouvoir se dire que
on veut se donner les moyens
donc tout ça ne sera pas forcément un
objectif de court terme ce ne sera pas
le grand big bang tout de suite on a
besoin d'abord de réagir et ensuite
qu'on va réagir on tire les leçons et
emmanuel macron qui doit présenter les
grandes lignes de la suite de son
quinquennat vous nous confirmer qu'il le
fera dans une interview à la presse
quotidienne régionale demain oui c'est
ce qui est prévu effectivement dont
grande interview
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous de ce
tournant finalement est ce que vous
attendez d'ailleurs un tournant est ce
que pour vous il faut changer de modèle
renverser la table ou pas pour moi le
tournant il a déjà eu lieu au moins
trois titres et d'ailleurs il faut dire
ce qu'on fait il faut l'assumer
il faut le revendiquer d'abord le
premier retournant le premier tournant
c'est celui de dire nous sommes pour le
retour des garanties et des libertés
fondamentales et la reconstruction de
cette ce contrat républicain
donc c'est ce que nous avons construit
donc ardue déconfinement pour vivre dans
des conditions qui soient les plus
normale possible ou si encore du
discours sur le lien de confiance entre
les citoyens et la police ça c'est un
premier tournant que nous devons assumer
comme tel le deuxième tournant c'est ce
dont nous parlons depuis le début de
l'émission en assumant que par la
dépense publique par une politique
keynésienne east de centre-gauche
appelez la comme vous voulez ça m'est
égal mais par cette politique là nous
assumons de soutenir à la fois
l'économie mais surtout de protéger les
travailleurs français et pas que les
travers français
les travailleurs en france pour être
plus précis ça c'est le deuxième
tournant avec finalement un côté assumé
dans lequel nous faisons de la relance
par la dépense publique et le troisième
tournant c'est que nous avions commencé
le quinquennat par une phrase qui était
celle protectrice des accords de paris
make our planet our planet green it
again il se trouve que ce message avait
qu il se trouve que le message n'a pas
plu j'étais forcément entendu et que les
conclusions de la convention climat qui
font écho à des propositions que nous
avions fait sur les versions thermiques
sur l'interdiction des vols moins de
deux heures et demie sur l'inscription
l'a déjà eu lieu ça veut dire que demain
ou pas de changement de modèle ça veut
dire aussi qu'on a su faire sinon on ne
change pas de ce que je vous dis c'est
que les grandes orientations elles ont
déjà été posées par contre il faut
d'abord les assumer clairement auprès
des français mais ça veut dire en assume
ce qu'on fait depuis le début du
quinquennat on ne change nord ne
renverse à lui dire qu'on ne les aime
pas on assume de ce qu'on fait depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire et que
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
on assume toutes les leçons que l'on en
tire si vous aussi vous voit encore un
exemple c'est la façon que nous
amplifions et nous dépassons finalement
tout ce que toutes les limites que nous
étions nous sommes fixés sur la question
du secteur de la santé avec 6 milliards
d'euros d'investissements avec des
augmentations de salaires qui sont non
plus des primes mais des revalorisations
de salaires
avec des plans d'investissement qui sont
sans commune mesure avec ce que nous
avions prévu de l'aveu même de la bouche
du prix d'omaha public par rapport à ma
500 la fois sociaux sociétaux et
environnementaux ça correspond
évidemment aux aspirations qui sont les
vôtres on annonce un remaniement dans
les prochains jours est-ce que
clairement vous vous inscrivez dans dans
la perspective peut-être de faire partie
du gouvernement pour porter ses
aspirations et la question se pose pas
comme ça avec la c'est comme ça que vous
là pour lui il le sait mais moi c'est
pas comme s'ils répondent actes et non
c'est pas comme ça que j'y réponds mais
vous avez vous raconterai pression sur
cette question d'abord c'est la question
c'est qu'est ce que nous voulons faire
et sur cette question on savait qu'on
n'était quelques-uns à bien il y avait
des choses qui n'allaient pas assez vite
transition écologique
moi j'avais même déposé cette
proposition de loi qui était une
proposition de loi construite avec
nicolas hulot sur l'article premier de
la constitution protection de
l'environnement dans l'arctique promet
la constitution on avait porté des
chaussures vient aujourd'hui exactement
est d'ailleurs qu'on avait construite
avec nicolas hulot au moment de la
révision des missionnaires donc sur ces
questions là quelle politique nous
voulons faire qu'est ce que nous disions
français quels sont les messages les
trois messages que je vous écris sur la
garant de la garantie des libertés
fondamentales l'emploi ou
l'environnement
quelles sont ses messages à partir du
moment où ces messages sont forts sont
assumés peu importe où nous sommes
selon le post peu importe que nous
soyons parlement vous riez les
justicières légitime pour porter ces
aberrations peu importe que nous soyons
parlement pour voter les budgets ou pour
porter loin peu importe que nous soyons
gouvernement pour en défendre les
grandes orientations
le but c'est quel message aujourd'hui la
majorité présidentielle envoie aux
français si ce message est celui-là
alors là moi vous voyez absolument
comblé parce que c'est parfaitement la
ligne politique que donc du coup vous
avez attaqué non je crois que personne
n'a été contacté à ce stade pas même les
principaux ministres donc naturellement
je n'ai pas été plus sur cette poussée
écologiste 1 qui a vu le jour dimanche
et ensuite aux européennes comment vous
situez la république en marge par
rapport à cette poussée écologiste est
ce que vous dites il faut attaquer les
verts ce sont des opposants très clair
ou est ce que vous dites banon il faut
qu'on essaye de travailler avec là aussi
ça m'inspire plusieurs choses d'abord on
peut assumer les choses
nous on n'a pas gagné dimanche et quand
on n'a pas gagné dimanche ça veut dire
qu'on a perdu ça on peut le dire la plus
grande perdante aussi c'est la
démocratie parce que quand vous voyez
les taux de participation on doit même
tous interrogé sur le fait que dans ma
ville à poitiers 32 % des électeurs sont
allés voter pour une élection qui
devrait être le graal si on écoute les
spécialistes de ce qui était souvent ce
qu'on met en avant un très bon a perdu
nomme mais là pour le coup c'est un peu
tout le monde a perdu avec cette
participation
mais moi je vous dis ça mais qu'il soit
élu avec elle sans moi je vous dis sans
fard qu'on a on n'a pas gagné donc on a
perdu donc pas de problème
non je pense qu'il ya une forte
décorrélation du local et du national
parce que d'abord c'est l'effet du non
cumul des mandats il faut l'assumer
ensuite parce qu'il ya une erreur c'est
donc une nuance jean damien je crois pas
je pense que c'est à chacun et à sa
tâche et chacun d'eux est pleinement à
sa tâche comme moi j'ai toujours défendu
le non cumul des mandats je n'ai pas
changé d'avis maintenant
et sur ce dernier sujet moi je pense que
les verts ne sont pas des adversaires
politiques
en revanche en revanche quand j'entends
le secrétaire générale d'europe écologie
les verts dire hier que la 5g et
finalement très consommatrice de
d'énergie je peux pas laisser passer ce
genre de technique donc moi je suis pour
que lorsque l'on avance en commun sur
des thématiques qui sont juste le
déploiement de parcs éoliens
l'investissement dans la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments ou en tout cas
le verdissement notre économie voire
même l'approvisionnement de nos cantines
par des circuits bio ou 100% locaux ça
j'ai pas de problème si c'est pour les
adversaires vous pourriez travailler
avec eux sur certains sujets faire des
fêtes news ou 6,6 pour promouvoir des
thèses qui sont des thèses anti
développement économique là c'est mal
parti pour une alliance du coup non mais
là par contre ils nous trouveront en
face moi je n'en fais pas des
adversaires de principe
ma contre politiquement on examinera
politiques publiques tant politiques
publiques si on est d'accord mais ce que
j'aime favorable à ce que des verts
rentrent au gouvernement
d'abord il y en a déjà eu ensuite nous
en avons même dans notre qui ont tenté
la porte avec fracas
ensuite nous allons même dans notre
parlement européen ils sont même
président la commission environnement au
parlement européen ensuite vous attend
dans notre groupe politique à
l'assemblée il en reste et donc moi j'ai
encore une fois je vous dis je vous dis
je des cierges et pas de problème avec
les verts au contraire par contre il
faut qu'on soit clair sur les politiques
publiques
on peut pas on peut pas accepter
n'importe quoi au prétexte d'une
étiquette et le but de lamah chronique
au départ c'était aussi de faire
travailler des gens malgré leur
étiquette politique d'assumer des
désaccords lors s'il existe et d'assumer
des convergences lorsqu'elles sont là
juste un an pour parler pardonne rien de
de la ma chronique comme vous le dites
on voit aujourd'hui que les aspirations
un peu plus social et plus écologique de
la république en marche mais bon ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué que dans les
autres partis est ce que vous sentez
toujours à l'aise dans ce parti est ce
que d'autres mouvements politiques ne
portent pas davantage les commandes
des aspirations que vous portez vous
d'abord faudra dire quel moment
politique parce que ce que je crois lire
ou ce que je fais ce que je vois au
sortir des élections municipales c'est
une un accroissement de la décomposition
de la vie politique
quelle est la droite aujourd'hui un
détournement de la république en a entre
autres mais quelle est la droite
aujourd'hui ce pays l'europe sociale la
droite libérale la droite conservatrice
la route catholique quelle est la gauche
aujourd'hui dans ce pays
la gauche écologique radicale la bauche
économique modérée la gauche socialiste
la gauche communiste
donc c'est à dire quoi ces cas à défaut
de trouver aujourd'hui aujourd'hui mais
en plus accueillants il n'ya dans la
république en or non ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons fait le pari
du nir à la fois la droite modérée la
droite libérale les radicaux le centre
gauche derrière du ce pari finalement
mais je crois pas mais je crois pas je
crois pas parce que s'ils voient que ça
tiraille un homme tous les n'a pas de
tradition qu'en marche ça n'a pas de
traduction locale qui avait fait de
démontrer sa pertinence aujourd'hui ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai en revanche au
niveau national
quand vous regardez important quand même
vous regardez les préoccupations qui
sont ces des français nous y répondons
si la préoccupation majeure des français
c'est l'emploi
nous y répondons s'il a probablement
renforce pas pardonnez moi monsieur
oublie ce manque d'assise le cal est ce
que cela ne renforce pas le côté un
petit peu hors sol tu peux avoir la
république en marche en tout cas ce
qu'on lui reproche parfois alors sur
cette question ça revient à refaire
l'éternel procès du conflit de
légitimité
et si j'allais dans ce conflit de
légitimité non voté lui depuis trois ans
je pense que plupart mais vous le fais
aujourd'hui même enfin en tout cas à
l'époque on nous avait quand même
beaucoup reproché la participation qui
était nettement supérieure à celle des
élections municipales mais sans parler
de la participation sur bosco d'ancrage
local
ce que je voudrais d'abord moi j'ai déjà
envoyé pas de sentiments y compris même
si nous n'avons pas gagné les élections
à poitiers ne pas avoir d' ancrage local
parce que l'ancrage local il se traduit
différemment que la recherche la quête
perpétuelle d'un nouveau mandat
l'ancrage local il semaine si mesure au
nombre d'appels que j'ai reçus
d'entreprises en difficulté au relais
qu'on aille et que les admins vous avez
encore les dates partout où ils vont
chercher dans la plupart des villes les
candidats on cherche à les traits du
canton des candidats ont cherché à être
élu on a on aura probablement
un bilan à faire aussi à la pico marche
à cette question on aura des stratégies
qui seront probablement différente dans
la plantation
on a fait ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
alors dans un asile mais aussi on est
aussi un jeune parti qui fait qu'on peut
assumer que est bien ce que nous avons
construit en 2017 ne peut pas se
reproduire à toutes les élections et on
peut pas assumer aussi que nous avons
besoin d'élus qui sont parfois est donc
régulièrement aujourd'hui des élus
d'opposition qui devront se faire une
expérience politique dans l'opposition
qui devront défendre des dossiers locaux
avant même d'arriver ensuite à des
responsabilités savez il ya des gens et
je peux prendre l'exemple de l'écologie
ce qui était lui à bordeaux qui ont fait
40 ans d'opposition avec leurs valeurs
et bien c'est les a pas empêché d'être
élu la fin et donc si toute leur vie
serait élue dans 40 ans du coup et ça
c'est peut-être mais peut-être mais
quand on a des convictions
moi jai ho savez j'étais strauss
kahniens au parti socialiste
c'était ce n'était pas vraiment la
tendance qui a permis de gagner ni en
2006 ni en 2011 ni en 2012
c'est mes idées aujourd'hui que j'estime
au pouvoir et c'est ce qu'on a décrit
lors de cette émission sur les
différentes lignes des orientations
ce qui veut dire que quand on conserve
ses opinions profondes ses convictions
et bien peu importe le moment où ça
arrive mais il faut se battre pour que
ce pour quoi on croit parce que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut faire la politique
et merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin vers 6h merci d'être venus